recently diagnosed with acid reflux  what's the culprit it could be your diet  your bad habits the stress of taking out  international terrorists sound familiar  mr. president if so you need mota SEC  the only solution proven to fight acid  reflux in the Oval Office other  medications take up to 24 hours to work  you don't have 24 hours in 24 hours you  could have experienced stressful  situations like a precipitous market  drop an unpleasant meeting with a  foreign leader or a historic defeat in  the midterm elections based largely on  the policies of your administration so  if the symptoms are clear tripodo sec  there's no time for surrender to grief  if you're the commander in chief warning  if symptoms persist consult your surgeon  general provided you no more proof by  the south